all right I want to start today with
some disinformation debunking and it has
to do with these talking points about
health care choice as some call it and
the reason that this is so important is
because health care choice the idea of
choice is being propagandized by both
the right and left including in some
cases by the left within the Democratic
primary as many of you will very quickly
recognize Buddha judge for example
talking about Medicare for those who
want it and therefore choose it or some
other thing Republicans like to talk
about how their general approach to
health care which is free-market for
profit etc their general approach is all
about letting the individual choose
falling under this umbrella of personal
liberty and choices better and more
options are better and the free market
is better but there's a reality that
underlies or more appropriately does not
underlie those assumptions about choice
being better and choice ik waiting to
Liberty and Liberty being objective
objectively better in all cases the
reality is no one really likes choosing
their health care plan and what I mean
by that is of the people who choose a
health care plan people are not
particularly happy with the choices that
they have I'll explain what I mean I
choose my health care plan okay I am in
a position unlike many because of their
relationships to their health insurance
plan
where I actually have arguably the
largest number of plans to choose from
that than many other people would have
the choices are terrible people who
choose their health care plans typically
are choosing from bad options in a
variety of different marketplaces
what am I talking about let's explain
most Americans get their insurance from
their employer and they have no choices
when they do have choices they're
typically all equally bad or you're
relatively satisfied because your
employer provides a really good health
insurance plan you're not really
choosing between anything the employer
has made the choices you either take the
one plan that's available
or you choose from a few plans that
aren't really good or you choose all
from plans that are really good
depending on where you work you might be
happy with it
you might not but the choice the idea of
choice being what makes you satisfied is
just flat-out a an imaginary assertion
number two if you're old enough to get
Medicare or poor enough to get medicaid
you also don't choose you get Medicare
or American Medicaid there's no choice
you might like it
you might lot not like it but there's no
choice involved there the people who are
choosing their plan like me I have my
own business it's a small business I go
to the marketplace in Massachusetts it's
called the health connector it's
terrible
I have choice more choice than most of
you have since most people either have
employer plans or Medicare or Medicaid
the choices are horrible my plan is
terrible the the the quote best option I
found balancing cost and benefits is a
plan that in 2019 cost me four hundred
and twenty-one dollars a month in 2020
is going up to four hundred and fifty
eight dollars a month increasing my
out-of-pocket maximums increasing my
co-pays do I seem happy with all the
choice that I have and there are several
dozen plans that I could choose from I
would much rather have no choices to
make because the government is providing
a single-payer system for example when I
first started the show like 13 years ago
I was just out of college he didn't have
a job etc my income was low enough that
I could get a really great plan there
was very little choice I just got the
plan that people get when they don't
make enough money to have to buy a plan
through what's called the health
connector that's why this entire talking
point about choice being objectively
better is BS but let's go further not
only is the idea of choice alluding to
something that's not even really that
good it was a fabrication of the health
insurance industry we have interviewed
on this program
former Cigna health insurance executive
wendell potter he wrote the book deadly
spin and we've interviewed him before
because he's blown the whistle about the
techniques that the health insurance
companies use he posted on twitter
recently he was involved in coming up
with this ruse that is the idea of
choice I'm going to read
his Twitter thread because he says it so
well and remember he came up with this
garbage to trick people
he wrote lately I've noticed some
Democratic politicians defending the
current health care system by saying
that it preserves choice for Americans
as a former health insurance executive
who helped draft this talking point I
need to come clean on its backstory and
why it's wrong and a trap
Wendell goes on to say when I worked in
the insurance industry we were
instructed to talk about choice based on
focus groups and people like Frank Luntz
who wrote the book on how the Republican
Party should communicate with Americans
I used it all the time as an industry
flack but there was a problem as a
health insurance PR guy we knew one of
the huge vulnerabilities of the current
system was lack of choice in the current
system you can't pick your own doctor
specialist or hospital without huge
out-of-network bills so we set out to
muddy the issue of choice as industry
insiders we also knew most Americans
have very little choice of their plan
your company chooses an insurance
provider and you get to pick from a few
different plans offered by that one
insurer usually either a high deductible
plan or a higher deductible plan another
problem insurance like insurers like
mine had on the choice issue people with
employer based plans have very little
choice to keep it you can lose it if
your company changes it or you change
jobs or turn 26 or many other ways this
is a problem for defenders of the status
quo knowing we were losing the choice
argument my pals in the insurance
industry spent millions on lobbying ads
and spin-doctors all designed to
Gaslight Americans into thinking that
reforming the status quo would somehow
give them less choice an industry front
group
launched a campaign to achieve this very
purpose it's named my care my choice its
job trick Americans into thinking they
currently can choose any plan they want
and that their plan allows them to see
any doctor they've spent big in Iowa
this isn't the only time the industry
made a choice made a choice a big
talking point in its scheme to fight
health reform soon after Obamacare was
passed it created a front group called
the choice and competition coalition the
scare states away from creating
exchanges with better plan
the difference is this time Democrats
are the ones parroting the misleading
choice talking point and they're even
using it as a weapon against each other
back in my insurance PR days this would
have stunned me I bet my old colleagues
are thrilled and celebrating the truth
of course is you have little choice in
health care now most can't keep their
plan as long as they want or visit any
doctor or hospital some reforms like
Medicare for all would let you in other
words Medicare for all actually offers
more choice than the status quo this is
a former insurance industry executive
telling you this and when dole finishes
by saying so if a politician tells you
they oppose reporter forming the current
system because they want to preserve
choice either they don't know what
they're talking about or they are
willfully ignoring the truth I assure
you the insurance industry is delighted
either way as Wendell says you have
Democrats now including Pete Buddha
judge and some others parroting what
were previously right-wing and health
insurance company talking points about
choice don't fall for it go and talk to
the few people who actually do choose
their health insurance under their
current system and you will very quickly
see that this is a ruse unfortunately
it's not a transparent one it's actually
working on a lot of people one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you $5.00 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a life saver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month
you can set spending limits you can
freeze them you can delete them any time
you want so when you do this it means
you're not going to be charged when you
don't want to be because you can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance I love using
free trials because I know I won't be
charged when the trial is over if I use
a virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman